[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEGAN GREEN: I'm very pleased
to have Seth Stephens-Davidowitz
here.
He has used data from the
internet, particularly Google
searches, to get new insights
into the human psyche.
Today we'll be discussing
his book and research
from "Everybody Lies."
Seth has used Google
searches to measure racism,
self-induced abortion,
depression, child abuse,
hateful mobs, humor,
sexual preference, anxiety,
and sexual insecurity,
among many other topics.
Some a little less depressing
than some of those, right?
Seth worked for one
and a half years here
as a data scientist at Google,
so that's really exciting,
and is currently a contributing
op-ed writer for "The New York
Times."
He's designing and teaching a
course at the Wharton School
where he will be a
visiting lecturer.
Seth received his BA in
philosophy from Stanford,
and a PhD from
Harvard in economics.
So please, let's give
Seth a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
All right.
Thanks everybody for attending.
Thank you, Megan,
for the introduction.
And it's great to be back here.
I did work for one and a half
years in Mountain View Google.
But I did come by
here a while ago,
and I forgot how
spectacular it is here.
So it's a nice reminder.
But it's nice to be here.
I'm talking about my
book "Everybody Lies,"
which is how we can use
data from the internet
to understand who we really are.
So for the last 80
years, if you wanted
to know what people want, why
people did the things they do,
what people will
do in the future,
you had one main approach--
you ask them, right?
You conducted a survey.
Gallup or Pew or
Quinnipiac would go around
and say, what do you want?
What are you going to do?
And the main
problem with this is
that people have been shown to
lie to surveys, particularly
on sensitive topics.
They try to make
themselves look good.
They tell surveys
what they think
the surveyor wants to hear,
not necessarily the truth.
So a classic example of
this is, if you ask people
before an election, are you
going to vote in the election?
A huge percentage, the
overwhelming majority
of Americans say, sure.
Of course I'm going to exercise
my civic duty and vote.
And then when the election comes
around, about 55% of Americans
vote.
So people don't want to say
that they're not voting.
One of my favorite examples is
the General Social Survey asks
Americans how frequently
they have sex,
and how frequently
they use a condom.
So according to
women, they have sex
on average about once a
week, and use a condom 20%
of the time.
So they say that they're using
1.1 billion condoms every year.
And then they also must say
whether it's gay or straight.
So they're using 1.1
billion condoms every year
in heterosexual
sexual encounters.
And then they asked
men the same questions.
And according to
men, they're using
1.6 billion condoms
every year in
heterosexual sexual encounters.
I hope everyone realizes
those, by definition, have
to be the same, right?
So we already know
that someone's lying,
someone's not telling
the truth here
about how much sex
they're having.
And I got data from Nielsen.
They track every condom
sold in the United States.
Only 600 million condoms
are sold every year.
[LAUGHTER]
So basically now
everybody's lying about sex,
it's just men are lying
even more than women.
And this doesn't
mean-- this could just
be they're lying
about using a condom,
not necessarily how
much sex they have.
But if you see how
much unprotected sex
women of fertility
age say they're
having, if they really
were having this much sex,
there would basically be
more pregnancies every year
in the United States.
So I think in our sex-obsessed
culture, there is now pressure,
both on men and women, to
say they're having more sex
than they actually are having.
All right, digital truth serum--
Google.
The thesis of my book
basically, and the thesis
of my research for
the last five years
is that people are much
more honest on Google
than they are to basically
any other source, I think.
People tend to feel comfortable
typing things into Google
that they might not
tell anybody else.
And this data of course is
all anonymous and aggregate,
so nobody knows the searches
that any particular person
makes.
But by aggregating it all
and putting it all together,
we can see different patterns in
human behavior and human wants.
So like, example--
people are honest--
tell things Google they
might not tell anyone else.
There are more
searches on average--
this is using Google Trends,
for porn than for weather.
Though if you ask people if
they watch porn, only about 20%
of men and 4% of women
say they watch porn.
So that's hard to reconcile.
But people are clearly
typing things into Google
that they might
not be comfortable
telling to a survey.
So we can learn,
really, lots of--
so why are people
so honest on Google?
Well, one thing they're
alone, they're online.
That tends to make
people more honest.
But they also have an incentive
to tell the truth to Google.
So there's no reason
for any person
to tell a survey that they're
voting-- about their voting
behavior, whether actually
voting or not voting.
There's no reason to tell--
to be honest about that.
But if you're someone who
doesn't always vote, or is kind
of a marginal voter,
you may not know
where the polling places are,
so you have to tell Google.
You have to say "where to vote,"
or "how to vote," or search
something like that.
And it is clear in the data
that this predicts turnout
in different parts
of the country,
that when people are
making a lot of searches
for where to vote
and how to vote,
people are much more
likely to turn out to vote.
And if you're not
having a lot of sex,
you don't have a reason
to tell that to a survey.
There's no reason
for you to do that.
But you might have an incentive
to search for this on Google.
And the number one complaint
about a marriage on Google
by far is that it's a
sexless marriage, much more
common than loveless
or unhappy marriage.
And we also start
seeing in this data
some things that are
maybe counter-intuitive or
surprising.
The number one
complaints about partner
on Google for husband, wife,
boyfriend or girlfriend
is that the partner
won't have sex with me.
Easily beats the
second place complaint
that the partner
won't text me back.
[LAUGHTER]
But there are actually twice
as many complaints on Google
that my boyfriend won't have sex
with me than that my girlfriend
won't have sex with me,
which goes completely
against conventional wisdom
about who's avoiding sex.
So I think there are definitely
surprising things in this data.
We can also use this
search data to answer
big, big questions that have
kind of puzzled researchers
for a while.
One of them that I've done a
lot of research on is on racism.
So this is kind
of a classic area
where it may be
difficult to find
the truth by using surveys.
And for example, after
the 2008 election, one
of the big questions
was, would voters--
did voters care that Barack
Obama, the first major party
general election candidate,
was African-American?
Did they care that he was black?
And if you ask in surveys,
the overwhelming majority
of Americans, 98%,
99% of Americans
said, no, I didn't care at
all that Obama was black.
It was not a factor
in my voting decision.
But of course, this
may be misleading
because people may lie, and
not want to admit that they
cared that Obama was black.
So what I did--
this is kind of
the first study I
did with this research is,
I studied racist searches
that people make on Google.
And this is
obviously disturbing.
This is a search for a
very, very nasty word about
African-Americans that you can
kind of guess probably what it
is, or look--
read my book if you
want to learn more.
But this is
basically just people
searching for disparaging jokes
mocking African-Americans.
So really, really
nasty searches.
And the first thing that struck
me out about these searches
was how frequent they were.
In the time period
I was looking,
this search was about as
common as searches for Lakers,
and Economist and
migraine and Daily Show.
So not, by any stretch of the
imagination, a fringe search.
And the other thing that
was striking about this
when I first saw this
data is that the map
looks very different than the
map that I would have guessed.
So if you were to ask me
before I did this research,
where is racism highest
in the United States?
I would have said south, right?
Deep south.
Like, that's-- when you think
of the country's history,
you think Mississippi
and Louisiana,
Alabama and South Carolina.
And those areas definitely
are among the highest,
but also among the
highest are West Virginia
and western Pennsylvania,
eastern Ohio and upstate New
York, and parts of industrial
Michigan and rural Illinois.
The real divide this map
reveals in racism these days
in the United States is
not south versus north,
it's east versus west.
So it's much higher.
Racism is much higher east
of the Mississippi River
than west of the
Mississippi River.
So how can you use
this map to detect
how much racism cost Obama?
Basically, I compared Obama to
previous democratic candidates
such as John Kerry, the
white candidate, who
was similarly liberal in
the previous candidate--
in the previous election.
And you see a very,
very clear relationship
that, in parts of
the country that
are making the most
racist searches
in western Pennsylvania
or eastern Ohio
and western Michigan, you
see a clear relationship
that Obama just does worse than
previous democratic candidates
did.
And you try to explain it by
any other variable you have,
and nothing else can really
explain this relationship
except racism.
So I think it was
really, really clear
in this data that despite
what people were saying,
a significant fraction
of Americans--
I say about four percentage
points overall he lost.
And about 10% of white
Americans would not
support a democratic candidate
just because he was black.
I think that's what I
picked up in this data.
And then I kind of--
this kind of languished in
academic journals for a while.
People weren't really
paying much attention to it.
But then in this
recent election,
Donald Trump started
saying some nasty things
about black people, right,
and was still getting
a lot of support.
And this was kind
of puzzling to a lot
of people who thought
that you're not really
allowed to say those things in
the United States these days.
So not me, but actually Nate
Cohn at "The "New York Times,"
a stats guy there, he
asked for this data.
He said, can I see your
racist search data?
I have data on
how Trump is doing
in the primary in all
different parts of the country,
and I want to see
if it correlates
with your racist search data.
And he found that it was
the single highest variable
that he could find.
It was higher than
age and education
and economic conditions
and trade and policy
positions and gun ownership.
Basically nothing could
explain support for Trump
in the primary to
the same degree
as this racist search did.
So I think what happened is,
the same hidden racism that
was hurting Obama but not being
picked up in the data also
helped carry Trump to victory.
So I think, yeah, this is
the digital truth serum.
And Megan is right, my book is
[LAUGHS] kind of depressing,
I think, a little bit.
[LAUGHTER]
Because yeah, like, if you
ask people what they're like,
they're going to give you a
more positive view of themselves
than they necessarily
really are.
So yeah, I talk
about racism, and I
talk about child abuse, and
do-it-yourself abortion.
I think America has a
do-it-yourself abortion
crisis that isn't being picked
up in the traditional data
sources.
So really dark, horrifying,
terrifying, disturbing
material.
But I put jokes in it,
so you won't really
notice just how miserable
all the findings are.
So I think there actually
is a lot of value
to knowing some of this
stuff, to knowing the truth,
even if it is sometimes
depressing, and sometimes
disturbing.
And I'll give you a
couple examples of that.
So one of the studies
I did is, I just
compared the Google
searches that people
make about sons and daughters.
And I would have thought or
hoped in the United States
today that parents treated
their sons and daughters
the same way.
But if you look at everybody's
search data together,
you see very, very
different patterns.
Where, when American parents
start a search "is my son,"
they're are about twice
as likely to complete it
with "gifted" or "a genius"
than if they start a search
"is my daughter."
And they start a search
"is my daughter,"
they're much more
likely to complete it
with "is my daughter
overweight," or even,
"is my daughter ugly?"
So despite what I think
parents might think,
there is clearly-- when you
put together everybody's data,
parents on average
are much more excited
about the intellectual
potential of their sons,
and much more concerned
about the physical appearance
of their daughters.
And I think that's one finding--
so you talk about the racism
thing, it's not clear
that the people who
are making these
racist searches,
if you just tell them,
they're going to be like,
oh, OK, I didn't
realize I was racist.
Sorry about that,
I'm going to stop
making these terrible searches,
joke searches, and stuff.
But I think with this
parenting finding,
I think a lot of
parents don't even
realize that they're doing that.
It's maybe a
subconscious prejudice
that they're not aware of.
And that's one where
maybe just the information
itself can actually
help to change behavior.
Where if we tell
parents, oh, you know,
you might not think so, but
look, when we put together
everybody's data even
throughout the United States
there are these prejudices.
Think twice.
Are you paying enough
attention to the report card
that your daughter
is bringing home?
Are you paying enough attention
to her intellectual interests?
And I think a lot of
parents have told me
that that has made them
think twice about some
of the questions they ask,
and some of the ways they
treat their sons and daughters.
So there is a lot of
value in knowing things,
knowing the truth,
not what people think
or what people say.
And another example
that I'm going to give
is about Islamophobia.
So if you can go back to
the San Bernardino attacks
in December 2015, if
people remember that,
it was two people with a Muslim
sounding name shot up basically
one of the guys' coworkers.
And it was kind of a big--
many, many people died, and
it was a big news story.
And right after this, there was
an explosion of Islamophobia.
And you saw that really, really
clearly in the Google searches,
where the number one
search with the word
Muslims in it immediately after
the attack was "kill Muslims."
And these are people
just kind of--
they're maniacs to some degree.
These are kind of just not the
most sane members of society.
It's not even clear what
exactly they're saying,
but they're saying--
but they're very
angry, and kind of just
want to do something bad.
And they also make searches like
"I hate Muslims," or "Muslims
must die," or
really, really nasty,
nasty, horrible searches.
And these searches
we've shown can
predict hate crimes in the
United States against Muslims.
So they're not-- even
though they're weird,
they definitely contain
meaningful information.
So a few days after the
San Bernardino attack,
Barack Obama gave a
talk to the nation.
And the theme of
this talk was both
that we had to protect
ourselves against terrorism,
but also we had to
fight this Islamophobia.
We couldn't really
allow ourselves to give
in to this hatred that some--
a small but dangerous
percentage of people
were letting
themselves give into.
And this speech was
nationally televised,
it got a lot of attention.
And it was one of the
more beautiful speeches
I'd heard Obama give.
It was kind of classic
Obama, but even better
than classic Obama
where he talked
about how it's
our responsibility
to not give into fear,
and to appeal to freedom,
and how it's our
responsibility to not reject
someone just because of
the religion they practice.
And it got great reviews from
all the serious sources, right?
The New York Times said
it was a great speech,
and the LA Times said
and the Boston Globe said
it was a great speech.
So it was-- kind of all
the conventional wisdom
was that Obama had
given this great speech
about our
responsibility to treat
our neighbors kindly, our
Muslim-American neighbors
kindly.
So Google breaks down minute
by minute their search data.
And I wanted to see, did
this beautiful speech
serve its purpose?
Did it calm down
these Islamophobes?
And I looked at the data.
And I found that not only
did these crazy searches--
"kill Muslims," "hate Muslims,"
"I hate Muslims," "die,
Muslims," they didn't drop.
They didn't even stay the
same, they went way up.
They exploded.
Basically every time
Obama was saying
all these responsibility--
the importance of
responsibility,
this beautiful sermon just
seem to backfire completely
on all the bio--
on its main purpose.
But there was one
line that Obama
gave at the speech that seemed
to have a different response.
So he said that we had to
remember that Muslim-Americans
are our friends and neighbors.
They're our athletes, and
they're our sports heroes,
and they're the men and women
who will die for this country.
And right after he said that
line, for the first time
in the last five
years, the top word
searched with Muslims was
not "Muslim terrorists,"
or "Muslim refugees," it
was "Muslim athletes,"
followed by "Muslim soldiers."
And these stayed up for
about a week afterwards.
And you saw throughout
the internet,
people were talking about,
Shaquille O'Neal's a Muslim?
I didn't know Shaquille
O'Neal was a Muslim.
And I think that does--
you can kind of compare
most of the speech versus
what that line was.
So the first part--
most of the speech was
basically a lecture
telling people everything they'd
heard a million times before.
Nothing new, right?
Lecturing them to be better
people than they were.
And that seemed to
totally backfire.
But the line about the
athletes and sports heroes
was provoking their curiosity,
giving them new information,
changing what they might
think of as a Muslim-American.
And that seemed to
be more successful.
So we wrote this up in a
column in the New York Times.
And I don't think
it's totally crazy
that, when you write a
New York Times column,
powerful people see that.
Because a couple weeks later,
Obama gave an other speech.
This time it was in
a Baltimore mosque.
And again, it was
on national TV.
And again, it got
a lot of attention.
And the content of the
speech was totally different.
Basically, he stopped with all
the sermon, all the lectures,
all the talk of responsibility.
And he just doubled down
or even quadrupled down
on the curiosity.
So he said that
Muslim-Americans are not just
our sports heroes
and our soldiers,
they're our farmers
and our merchants.
And he talked about how
Thomas Jefferson had
a copy of the Quran, and
how Muslim-Americans built
the skyscrapers of Chicago.
So it was all these new
images of Muslim-Americans
that we didn't previously have.
And I looked at the search
data again after this speech,
in the hours following
this speech, and this time
the searches for "kill Muslims"
and "I hate Muslims" dropped.
So I think-- that's
only two speeches,
and I don't want
to say that we've
solved the problem of hatred.
But I do think that this
is a radically new tool.
And I think people don't
realize just how revolutionary
this data from the internet
is, that we can actually
peer into an angry mob, and
turn that into a science, right?
In a survey of all
Americans, you're
not going to get,
necessarily, these people.
And even if you do,
they may not be honest.
And they're not going
to agree to participate
in a lab experiment at
Princeton or Harvard.
But because Google
searches contains
everybody's information,
they're going to be on there.
And we can actually see how they
respond to big national events,
and maybe learn a
lot of the things
that we thought
worked don't work.
But here are things
that actually work.
So I think that kind of
shows that this window
into some parts of the psyche
that are disturbing but are
usually missed can really
serve a useful purpose,
where knowing the truth
is maybe the first step
towards improving
the world, I think.
So that's all I have to say.
Now I think we're going to
take questions from Megan
and other people about the book.
MEGAN GREEN: All right.
Hi, Seth.
That was great.
The book's awesome.
It's really cool if
you work at Google
because you can see sort
of what's going on here
in sort of a different variation
of what we do here every day.
So I highly recommend it.
And that was just a few of
the topics that you cover.
You cover so many
topics in the book.
But I thought I'd
start asking you
a little bit about your
experience working here,
and how that sort of led
you to become a writer.
And if there's anything
you miss about being here.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, no.
I didn't miss it until I
just had, like, the food--
[LAUGHTER]
--right before I got here.
I'm like, oh, man.
What was I thinking?
And the views of all--
they have a new floor here
in the New York office where
you can see the river,
and it's just like, oh
my-- and all the furniture
is so comfortable.
So yeah.
Yeah, and the people
are all really smart.
So I definitely-- you
don't appreciate what--
what's the song?
Joni Mitchell song,
you don't know
what you got till it's gone?
MEGAN GREEN: Yeah.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
So that kind
of happened a
little with Google.
Although I am enjoying the
writing thing as well, but--
MEGAN GREEN: And
what was it like when
you were working here?
And what were you working on?
Can you give a little
bit of color around--
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
So I was working
under Hal Varian,
the chief economist at Google.
He's the guy who
initially hired me.
And then I was on his team, and
also in quantitative marketing
out in Mountain View.
So kind of a lot of
in-house data consulting,
but also some advertising
effectiveness studies.
And then I did,
also, some research
because I think Google was kind
of getting interested in all
this information we have.
That's kind of one of
the original reasons
that Hal hired me, that there
is this powerful data, and kind
of how should we be
using this information?
MEGAN GREEN: And that was sort
of part of the inspiration
for this book, yes?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
I think-- I mean,
it's just, the more
I studied this data,
the more I'm like, wow,
this stuff is really important.
And there is a lot of
important information.
So I kind of wanted to
get that message out.
MEGAN GREEN: Cool.
So in talking about
the information,
sometimes you get an
answer and you go, wow,
that totally makes sense.
And sometimes you
get an answer that
is sort of contrary to what
you would think the data
would predict.
And so there's a lot of
psychology involved in this.
Can you talk a little
bit about how often
that sort of happens,
that the answer is
what you would expect?
And how do you kind of
come to your conclusions
when you get an answer that's
totally different than what
you thought it would be?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
I think frequently things are
just different than I expected.
So I've done a lot of
research on anxiety.
And I thought anxiety was
highest in New York City.
Because I'm from
New Jersey, right?
I'm from New Jersey, right
outside New York City.
I'm Jewish, it was
always like, oh, you're
a neurotic Woody Allen type.
I always thought I was a
really anxious, neurotic type,
and that that was a normal--
and that we were all way more
anxious than everybody else.
But then you see
in the search data
that it's not true
at all, that anxiety
is highest in Kentucky
and upstate Maine,
and rural areas way
more than urban areas,
and places with lower
levels of education
more than higher
levels of education.
So yeah, I think it just, over
and over again, the data--
I think we're just basically
blind to the world.
I think a lot of times
we think whatever's
going on in our own head is
much more general than it is.
Or we jump to conclusions
very, very fast.
So that's why I think the
data is usually different
than I expect.
I mean, sometimes it's not.
Like, if you search where
do people search for Lakers,
it's Los Angeles.
And you probably didn't need--
OK, that makes sense.
I'm not going to,
yeah, shock the world.
Like, no, the Lakers are
more popular in Minneapolis
than Los Angeles.
That's not true, but--
MEGAN GREEN: So has that
helped control your anxiety?
Because you're like, wow,
those people in Maine,
they've got it way
worse than I have here.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, no.
I think it-- it's just changed
how I thought about things.
I'm like, oh, wow, that's not--
it's even very particular
types of anxiety.
Like anxiety about
death, people make
searches "anxiety about death."
And I'm like, oh,
that's the Woody Allen
neurotic, intellectual thing.
But it's not true.
There are more of these
searches in Kentucky
and Alabama and Louisiana.
So it's just kind
of interesting.
And I definitely do kind
of go through the world
differently than I did before.
MEGAN GREEN: That's
super interesting.
So you ask a lot of questions?
I mean, we just talked
about how many Americans
are really racist, who
cheats on their taxes,
does advertising work?
But I'm sure there
are a lot of things
that got left out in the book.
So can you talk a
little bit about how
you go about
choosing your topics,
and if there was
anything interesting that
maybe didn't make the cut?
Because there's so many
interesting factoids.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
I don't really-- there's not
a science to choosing a topic.
You just kind of go
around the world,
and talk to a lot of people,
and read a lot of things.
And then one thing
sparks a question,
or you play around
with data, and it goes
in a totally other direction.
So I don't-- so I think
that didn't make it.
I have all this stuff
on anxiety that's
just not ready for
prime time that got cut.
I could have had--
I wanted to have three
chapters on anxiety
because I just find it
really, really interesting.
MEGAN GREEN: So that's
a whole other book
that we can look forward to?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, that's my next book.
But yeah, so I've done
this research on--
if you break down the minute
by minute when people make
searches for panic attacks.
And it's not surprising.
When do people make
searches for panic attack?
Like 2:00 AM, 3:00 AM, right?
They're in a cold sweat in
the middle of the night.
But what this basically means
is that now because this data,
we know on every given night,
we have a pretty good estimate
of how many people are having
panic attacks in New York
City and Boston and Los
Angeles and Indianapolis.
And we can basically say,
OK, why are, on some nights,
a lot of people
having panic attacks?
Or is there something
that happened
three days before, or two days
before, or the day before?
So there's really just so
much information here that--
I think it's revolutionary.
But some people criticize me for
being too grandiose about it,
but--
MEGAN GREEN: No, I
think that's great.
You got to sell it, right?
Yeah, I think that data
is totally fascinating,
I agree with you, and that
it applies to so many things.
So back to the
election a little bit,
you talked a little
bit about that.
And you kind of
outsmarted Nate Silver.
Would you say that that might
be correct in some ways?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
No, I wouldn't say that.
[LAUGHTER]
MEGAN GREEN: Are you--
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Especially since I'm trying
to get him to agree to let
me write a column for his--
[LAUGHTER]
--for his site.
MEGAN GREEN: Are you
looking at data now?
And what are you seeing in
terms of trends in politics
now that Trump is in office?
What's the follow-up
to what we heard
you say about this sort of
wave of populism and so forth?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, so the thing about
the election--
so there's a question just
starting with politics--
can you predict elections
with Google searches?
Because if you looked at
the surveys this year,
they didn't really
work so well, right?
The surveys told us that Hillary
Clinton was going to win,
then Donald Trump won.
So is there a way to use all
this information on the Google
where people are so honest
to predict elections?
And it's not so simple.
The top way most people have
tried to do it initially
was, you just see, are people
searching for a candidate more?
So if people are
searching for Trump more,
they're going to go Trump.
And if people are
searching for Clinton more,
they're going to go Clinton.
And you can probably
think yourself
why that wouldn't
really work, right?
Because you're not saying
whether you like the candidate
or you hate the candidate.
You could search for
Trump because you like him
or because you hate him.
So one of the indicators I
found with Stuart Gabriel, who's
a professor at UCLA, we found
there is an indicator that
has surprising predictive
power, and it's
the order in which
people search candidates,
which is pretty interesting.
It's basically if people--
25% of the searches people
make with Clinton also
include the word "Trump."
So people search for
"Clinton Trump polls,"
or "Clinton Trump debate,"
or "Clinton Trump election."
But if people search
Clinton before Trump,
they're much more
likely to go Clinton.
And if they search
Trump before Clinton,
they're much more
likely to go Trump.
So it's like something
subconscious.
If you're a Trump
supporter, you're
much more likely to think of
as a Trump/Clinton election.
If you're a Clinton
supporter, you're
much more likely to
think the reverse.
And then you could see
that in general, Trump
came before Clinton more.
And then this was more true in
key midwest battleground states
where he got victorious.
But I think it's going
to take many, many more
years of analyzing this
data before we know exactly
how to weight it and stuff.
But there definitely is a lot
of information in this data
that would be missed
by other sources.
MEGAN GREEN: That will give you
something to do for a long time
to come.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
There's no shortage of
things to do with this data.
MEGAN GREEN: Cool.
I'm going to invite
everyone here
to start lining up at the
mic if you have questions.
So please come on up.
And in the meantime, I'll
ask you one more question.
So some of the data
gets personal, right?
You talk about being
a Mets fan, or--
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
That's not embarrassing, is it?
MEGAN GREEN: No.
Just a little.
Or you talk about
what women should do
on a date to get a second date.
So how much of this came from
sort of your own personal life?
And is that a big way that
you sort of select topics?
And does that make you
feel more justified
in your everyday experiences?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: No.
A few of the topics were
my personal interest.
A lot of the sports stuff
was my personal curiosities.
MEGAN GREEN: You wanted to
be a baseball player, yes?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Basketball player.
MEGAN GREEN: Basketball player.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
But I would
settled for a baseball player.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, but I think-- but
like the racism stuff,
I don't think I'm
particularly racist.
Or I did stuff on gay-- there
are a lot of closeted gay men.
I'm not gay, but I thought that
was really interesting, too.
So I don't know.
It's not all-- it's probably
20% personal-based, but--
MEGAN GREEN: Fair enough.
OK, I'm going to turn it
over to you guys at the mic.
And I'm going to
turn on the mic.
Is it not on?
It should be on.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
OK.
So I was struck by
something you said,
which was that people are
partially more honest online
and with Google searches
because they have
an incentive-- they're
trying to get something
from their search.
But then some of the
searches that you
cited with the racism research
and some of the others,
like "I hate
Muslims," and things
that didn't seem to be a
question, which you would think
is the incentive with a search.
To what do you attribute
that type of honesty?
Because it sounds
like those people
are not, at the very least,
seeking additional information
on a topic, which is our
usual definition of a search.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, that's a great question.
So yes, so there are two
reasons that Google is honest.
The one is the incentive thing.
So if you're talking
about a sexless marriage
or racist jokes or
information on voting,
where there's sensitive topics
but you need the information.
And there's this other
class of searches
that totally shocked me.
It was one of the most
surprising things in the data.
But it happens in big numbers.
People just confess
things to Google.
[LAUGHTER]
So they say, "I hate my
boss," or like, "I'm sad,"
or, "I'm drunk."
And it's just like,
OK, like why are you--
[LAUGHTER]
--why are you telling Google?
And I think a lot
of it is, it's kind
of similar to the
confessional, right?
The Catholic confe--
like, just something--
I think people treat it
as-- like a confessional,
there's no purpose
to saying things.
But there's something about
saying things that you
wouldn't tell anybody else.
And people seem to
use it in that way.
And yeah, it's
really surprising.
My favorite example is that--
I talk about how men are
insecure about their bodies.
So we usually think that women--
that body insecurity is
predominately a female thing.
And it is majority female, but
if you look around the web,
it's close.
It's 55/45 women versus men.
And men are really insecure
about their bodies as well.
And a lot of this
insecurity, not surprisingly,
focuses on one particular
body part, and the size of it
in particular.
Men ask more questions
about their Whatever than--
[LAUGHTER]
--than any other body part.
But then one of
their top questions
they ask about this body part
is, "how big is my penis?"
Which is the
strangest search ever.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, so it's
the strangest search ever.
So people make, like, the
weirdest searches on Google.
It's very bizarre.
AUDIENCE: Follow-up
question, if I may--
have you done any sort of--
or is there data correlation
analysis between,
for example, people
confessing on various forums and
Reddit and sort of places where
you would confess, I think, with
an expectation of other people
saying, oh, me,
too, and searches.
Do they spike at
the same time maybe,
or are they localized in
the same way geographically?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
I haven't seen it.
It's a good question.
Some of the Google searches,
I think that is it,
that you kind of--
if you type "I'm sad," you might
get message boards where people
are saying, oh, I'm sad, too.
So it might be
that you're looking
for people who are feeling
the same way as you are.
And just by saying it in that
way, you get that information.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for coming today.
So when I do a search, often
I'll have one thing in mind.
But as I'm typing
the search, I'll
see the autocomplete suggestion.
And even though it's not at
all what I meant to search,
I might, out of curiosity,
complete that, and just
have that search anyway.
I'm wondering how
you account for that.
Or how do you know that's
trivial if a lot of people
do that.
Because you don't want to
count those, like double count,
right?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Well, it's
not clear you don't
want to count them.
I think it makes--
I don't know what percent of
searches-- somebody at Google
probably knows what percent
of searches use autocomplete.
I don't know that number.
I don't think it's
publicly available.
But I think it makes
small differences.
In could magnify initial
differences, right?
If people initially
have to search something
to get there, but
then the winner
will get potentially
more and more popular.
So I don't think it totally
changes the level of things,
like the ranking of things.
But it can make a bigger
difference between the top
and the other ones.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So overall, you're
saying that when
you do look at the
top search results,
you do keep in mind to
scale down a little bit just
to account for that?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
And I think the
regional ones are
pretty-- the regional
differences are still
pretty meaningful since,
from my understanding,
they don't, on average, get
very different autocompletes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: On your
early chart that you
had the comparison with
racism and correlation
to Donald Trump, my
question would be,
what was that
compared to Hillary?
Because was that
a flip, or was it
very similar in the two charts?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: So
that was the primary voting.
So it wasn't-- so you're saying,
what happened the general
election?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, I
think the general election
is a little more complicated
because it's like, Democrats and
Republicans differ in general.
So it's not-- most of the
reason that one area goes
Democrat and one area
goes Republican it's just,
it's more Democrat and
Republican area in general.
So you really want to compare
it to previous elections.
And that's also a
little complicated,
because then Obama had this
racism problem, and then Trump.
I think it's
basically that Trump--
a Republican
candidate who didn't
appeal to racism in the
way that I think Trump did
would have lost a lot of votes
in places relative to Obama
in parts of the country
with lot of racist searches.
But Trump didn't
lose those votes.
So places like West Virginia
and western Pennsylvania
and eastern Ohio,
if it was a norm--
if it was a different Republican
candidate, those areas,
they didn't like Obama.
But they would've maybe
come back to a Democrat.
But because Trump appeals
to those same feelings that
made them mad about Obama,
they went Trump's way again.
AUDIENCE: OK, because of the
variation between the primary
and the general
election then probably
has a great deal of effect that
wouldn't have been in that--
the correlation between
those two charts
might have been quite
different if they
were done at the same time.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
Well like I said,
the general election
is a little more complicated
because most of it is--
the map of any particular
general election
is very similar year to year.
So really, you just
want to see the changes
in behavior, the changes in
votes in a general election.
AUDIENCE: OK, very good.
Thank you.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, how's it going?
Quick question.
You mentioned earlier how
people lie on surveys,
and we have the product
Google Consumer Surveys.
So I was wondering if there's
any type of techniques
or things you've seen from
data collection via surveys
like OK Cupid, answer publicly
versus answer privately,
have you seen
anything that either
yielded more consistent
or reliable results
from a survey-based format?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
So there
are-- so online surveys tend to
be better than phone surveys,
for example, because I
think talking to someone
makes people that
much more dishonest.
I think there are all
these games that scholars
have invented to try to trick
people into telling the truth.
And you can kind
of look them up.
It's random digit examples,
or list experiments.
They basically ask
people 10 questions.
One of them is
embarrassing and the other
aren't, and ask how many
are true, yes or no.
And then can kind of
back out, and then
ask another group that,
except the embarrassing one
kind of can back
out the difference,
if that makes sense.
But my understanding is that
these don't really work,
although a lot of papers have
been written about it that they
don't really work.
I think Google
Consumer Surveys has
another pretty huge problem,
which is that people just
answer randomly.
Because at least if you're
answering a phone survey,
you've gone through the time
to not hang up right away,
you might give a--
take it somewhat seriously.
But I think Google
Consumer Surveys,
a big percentage of the people
don't give a serious answer.
AUDIENCE: Or for the app--
the screener questions,
they always answer
whatever they think
that we want to screen in for.
Yeah.
And then also, by the way, the
[INAUDIBLE] amplification study
you worked on, the
clients really liked it.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, that was another
thing that I worked on.
No, OK.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are you concerned at all
about the Hawthorne Effect?
By talking about what we can
learn from the Google search
results, maybe
people won't be as
willing to put their dirty
laundry out in Google?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
I don't know if it's
what we can learn.
There definitely are
changes in behavior.
So this is all based on the idea
that people will tell anything
to Google.
But someone did a paper where
they compared Google searches
before and after Snowden's leak.
And they found that there
was a big drop in searches
that were either sensitive--
so like on sensitive topics
or embarrassing topics.
Actually, my favorite
thing from the paper
is that they had
a list of emba--
they had to figure out
what's embarrassing search.
So they asked people
at Mechanical Turk
to rank the embarrassment
of searches.
And one of them that got
classified as embarrassing
was Nickelback.
[LAUGHTER]
And then they found that
those types of searches
did drop, including Nickelback--
[LAUGHTER]
--after Snowden's revelation.
So yeah, I don't think--
yeah, it may be that this is
a brief period of time where
we can really see
into the human psyche,
and then it'll all
die down or something.
I hope not, but I think--
I always emphasize that--
everyone's like, has
your search behavior
changed since you've
done this research?
And it hasn't at all because I'm
like, nobody knows my search.
I don't see why it
should affect me
if they know that
someone in Brooklyn
is making a search or something.
It doesn't seem like--
AUDIENCE: Although
if I was a racist,
I might not want to give my
state a bad name by doing
lots of racist searches.
I don't know, if I felt bad
about being racist, maybe.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
So it could be like--
yeah, that's kind of a subtle--
I mean, that definitely would
be a problem in polls as well.
But I don't know if that's--
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Have you thought about comparing
the Google search results
with their social
network results or posts?
Are the social
network results tend
to be more, or as honest,
as Google search terms,
or even more honest
because people
use that as a way to
express themselves
and not necessarily exposing
their true identity?
Or people still-- or Google
search results tend to be more
honest than the social--
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
No, I think no question,
Google search results are
more honest than social media.
So I think that
social media data,
you can't really trust because--
it's even, in some sense,
worse than surveys.
Because you have an
incentive to make
yourself look good, to
impress your friends.
So if you compare, for example--
one example I talk
about is the popularity
of the "National Enquirer"
versus the "Atlantic Monthly."
That the "National
Enquirer" actually sells--
it's kind of a lowbrow,
trashy magazine.
That actually sells more copies
than the "Atlantic Monthly"
every year.
But on social media,
the "Atlantic Monthly"
is 45 times more
popular because everyone
wants their friends they
think they're really, really
intellectual, right?
And then it actually
is interesting
if you compare the social
media posts and Google search
posts, Google searches.
So if you look at the top ways
people describe their husband
on social media, the
top five descriptors,
"my husband is," it's "my
husband is amazing," "so cute,"
"awesome," "the best," and "my
best friend," which is probably
a misleading view of marriage,
to some degree at least.
And then if you do
Google, the top five
completes of "my
husband is" on Google--
which also kind of a
weird search to make,
but people do make "my
husband is," one of them
is also awesome.
So that checks out, but the
other ones are "gay," "a jerk,"
"mean," and "annoying."
So it's really-- yeah,
it's kind of interesting.
I think you get--
I'm not sure if one of them
is right or wrong on marriage,
but it's definitely very
different because on one you're
trying to impress your
friends, and on one you're not.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
Very interesting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm curious.
Looking at that map, is
there a way to tell--
or do you tell the difference
between two regions where
there are--
like one where there's a
lot of people doing those,
for example, racist searches,
or another area where
it's like fewer people doing
a lot of searches per person.
Do you account for multiple
searches per person?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, no, it's a good question.
No, that data is just
not made available.
I don't know if anyone
at Google has it,
but it's not made available.
Except what Google does
in Google Trends is,
they take out-- if someone
makes a lot of searches
in a short period of time,
it just counts as one search.
So it's not like someone
just in a half hour
searched this thing
over and over again,
and that's driving the results.
I think it is an interesting
comparison, I think.
In some ways, it's an
advantage to this data
relative to surveys.
Because I think
surveys, not always,
but we usually think of
as yes or no, as binary.
Either you are racist
or you aren't racist.
But there clearly are
degrees of it, right?
You're more or less likely.
So sometimes it's
an advantage, it
includes people who've
done it a lot of times
because they're probably
even more racist.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MEGAN GREEN: Cool, OK.
I just have a few more.
Thank you, everybody.
Those were great questions.
So I know you
spent a lot of time
talking about naming your
book, and went through a bunch
of sort of different names.
Can you talk a little
bit about the process
of naming a book, and how
you came to Everybody Lies?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Well, so yeah.
So that's why I
initially brought up
that ridiculous question that
men asked, because that's
what I wanted to call my book.
[LAUGHTER]
I wanted to call it
How Big Is My Penis?
What Google Searches--
MEGAN GREEN: That's where
I was going with that.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: --What
Google Searches Reveal About
Human Nature.
But then my publisher's
like, people
will be embarrassed to
buy that in an airport.
So I couldn't title it that.
But I think-- although
I still kind of think
that was a better title.
[LAUGHTER]
Although I do like this.
This title I didn't think of.
That was-- They came
up with this title.
And I think it's good.
I don't know.
MEGAN GREEN: I like it.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, I like it.
I think it gets a
lot of the point.
MEGAN GREEN: What about
some of the other data
sources you look at?
I mean, obviously you look at
Facebook, you look at Pornhub,
you look at a variety
of different sources.
How did those rank
compared to Google?
And are you planning on
looking more at other sources,
or is Google for you sort
of the ultimate place to be?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
I think Google's just way
better than all the other
ones because the honesty.
And then it just kind of--
it's so universal.
A lot of these data
sources, Twitter--
like, who uses Twitter?
It's a very selected sample.
But pretty much
everybody uses Google.
And then just any topic,
there is information there--
like music or race or
sexuality or anything.
There's probably at
least some insights.
MEGAN GREEN: Whereas
Pornhub is pretty specific.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And like, they're
kind of more one-offs.
You can find something
interesting in the data set,
but it's not as
comprehensive with Googling
and find something interesting
on any topic, I think.
So it's more of a--
I think it's orders of magnitude
better than the other data
sources.
MEGAN GREEN: We
like to hear that.
That keeps us in business.
So you mentioned before that
you kind of have a grandiose--
I actually think it's a really
sort of enlightening sense
of where data science is going
for both philosophy, medicine,
sort of how it can be
used to really help
people in the future.
And so I was sort of wondering
if you had any advice.
I know we have a lot
of data scientists
out there, both at
Google and in the world.
What advice would you give
them in terms of data science,
what they should be doing,
and where it's going?
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
I think it's--
I just think it's a really,
really exciting area just
because of all this new
data that's out there.
I think the insights that are
coming are going to be huge.
I would say that some--
obviously if people work at
Google, part of their job
is probably going to be a
lot of-- a decent percentage
of Google employees have to get
people to click on ads, which
is not necessarily the most
interesting, in my opinion,
use of data, but is important
for Google's business.
But I definitely
think the health stuff
is really valuable.
There is a study--
how much time do we--
MEGAN GREEN: You're
fine, go ahead.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ:
So there
was this study that was done
by Microsoft researchers
in collaboration with a
professor at Columbia.
And they studied
pancreatic cancer.
I talk about in the book.
They studied pancreatic cancer.
And they basically
could figure out that--
they studied anonymized,
de-identified individuals,
their search behavior over time.
And they said that--
and they could
guess based on
someone's searches
that they maybe got a
diagnosis of pancreatic cancer.
Because people typed
something like, "just
diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer, what do I do?"
Or very, very clear
searches that they
had pancreatic cancer.
Then what they did is,
they compared these people
to another group of
users who were similar
and never had such a diagnosis.
Then they looked at the searches
in the months leading up
to that diagnosis,
so the symptoms
that people were searching.
And they said, what symptoms
do people search that tells us
in two or three
months they're going
to have a diagnosis
of pancreatic cancer?
And the key to--
the reason this study's
potentially powerful
is, if the earlier you get a
pancreatic cancer diagnosis,
the higher your
chances of survival.
And using this data, they
found really subtle patterns
to the point that, if you
search for indigestion
before abdominal
pain, that's a risk
factor for pancreatic cancer.
Whereas if you search
just indigestion alone,
that's not a risk factor
for pancreatic cancer.
So they had so much
data, they could pick up
these really subtle patterns.
I'm kind of scared.
Whenever I hear this
story, it's like--
right after I read
that paper, I thought
I had indigestion followed
by abdominal pain.
MEGAN GREEN: That's going
to be in the anxiety book.
SETH STEPHENS-DAVIDOWITZ: Yeah.
So I don't want everyone to go
home and be like, oh crap, I
got pancreatic cancer.
But I think that's a really
impressive way to do medicine,
relative to what we usually do.
That's a pattern that--
I talked to the researchers.
Doctors don't know that
series of symptoms.
If you think the way that
doctors now diagnose diseases,
it's not as sophisticated
as a time series
of people's symptoms over
time, and a huge sample
to pick up patterns like that.
So I'm kind of--
a lot of people after
that said, so what
are the ethical implications?
Should a search company, if
they know this information,
should they tell you?
Right below your
button I Feel Lucky,
You Have Pancreatic Cancer,
or You Might Have Pancreatic
Cancer, like, that's kind
of a depressing thing
to see on a search engine.
But I think-- so I
think that they should,
but you should be
able to opt into it.
Say, if I'm the type
that wants information,
you should be able to say, hey,
if you can mind these patterns,
and potentially, if I have some
series of symptoms that tell me
that I'm at a risk of
a disease, and if I
am told that, I'll increase my
odds, I want to be told that.
But I go even further.
I think that these businesses
now have an obligation
to be researching this
to potentially find
patterns of symptoms.
Because I'm kind of
pissed that there
may be diseases that, just
because not enough data
scientists at these companies
are looking into it,
they may be picking up
patterns in my symptoms
that could potentially
save my life.
So I think that--
I go even more extreme
and think that there
is an ethical
obligation of companies
who have this data to be really
figuring out the health stuff,
there.
MEGAN GREEN: So
big implications.
And with that, let's give
Seth a round of applause
for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.